so um we are doing Octavius and the
birth of the Roman Empire today okay so
um let's review where we are the area is
44 BCE and Julius Caesar has just been
assassinated um and the three main
conspirators uh there are 60 Senators
but the three main conspirators are
Marcus buddhis who is considered the
leader of the
conspiracy um casassus
and uh Deus Buddhist okay and after they
assassinated um Caesar obviously Rome is
in
toror and Mark Anthony who is currently
the council or the head of state in Rome
um he reaches an
agreement with these conspirators the
agreement is this Mark Anthony who is a
staun uh
Ally of Julius Caesar he will not seek
retribution and in return the
conspirators will
declare that Caesar was not a tyrant he
did not want to become king okay so a
peace settlement was reached to avoid a
civil
war
um the problem is that Mark Anthony was
working behind the the scenes to work up
the Roman people against
conspirators and eventually um public
sment was so much against the
conspirators that to flee to the
provinces okay and then uh Mark Anthony
read the will of Caesar okay Caesar's
will remember that there's private
property in Rome and so when a man dies
he has a will and and then this will
stipulates how this private property
will be distributed
okay and there are three really
surprising things about the
will the first thing is
that Caesar right now is the wealthiest
man in Rome and he stipulates that upon
his death every Roman citizen will get
three months of a soldier's wage that's
a lot of money okay that's extreme
generosity he also stipulates that a lot
of his private property will be turned
into public parks for the benefit of the
Roman people so this will demonstrates
Jesus's love of his people
okay the second thing is actually more
surprising Mark Anthony believe believed
that he would be he would be named the
hear to Caesar's Legacy and wealth in
the in the will
but in fact Caesar names his complete
stranger to be his hair his name is
Octavius and Caesar named Octavius to be
his adopted
son and so um Octavius name is actually
gay Octavius and upon the adoption of
upon his adoption he is now named gayes
Julius Cesar
Octavius this is like much too
complicated so historians use to
shorthand
Octavian okay so we will name now name
this person Octavian and this is the
historical shorthand even though this is
this is not his real name so that's a
second big surprise in the will and the
third big surprise is
this Caesar names secondary hers these
are individuals who uh will inherit
Caesar's property and Legacy if avian
were to die Mark Anthony is a secondary
here but so is Decimus
Brutus one of the man who conspired to
kill
Caesar okay so this will of Caesars it
is
shocking uh and it shows to the people
that Caesar really loved them and that
Caesar loved everyone includ including
the people who conspired to kill him
okay Mark
Anthony um is very upset about this will
so that when Octavian and Octavian right
now he's only 18 years old okay he's
only 18 years old and he returns to
claim his legacy Mark Anthony AR Mark
Anthony is so upset that he refuses to
meet with Octavian and he
refuses to give E's property and wealth
to Octavian remember the first um
stipulation of the will is that every
Roman citizen will be given three months
of wages okay and Octavian what he does
is to honor cus will he borrows money
and this is a lot of money in order to
ensure that every citizen got three
months of
wages um so in this situation okay and
this is only a few months after sheas
deatha this is now a volatile Game of
Thrones situation Game of
Thrones Mark Anthony considers himself
the legitimate
hearer of Caesar and refuses to
acknowledge octav Octavian Octavian has
returned and demands to be acknowledged
as the hear okay so that's one um
conflict the other conflict is you have
these three conspirators Decimus
Buddhist um Marcus Buddhist
and Casas and they're not in Rome but
they're in the provinces with huge
armies okay so Des Buddhist he is in Gul
uh Marcus buddas and casassus are in the
Roman East which includes Anatolia and
Syria okay extremely wealthy provinces
where they have many loyal soldiers and
they understand that eventually there's
a conflict coming so they rais a huge
Army about 100,000 soldiers to prepare
for the event ual conflict and this is
like the largest army ever assembled in
Roman
history um you also have a name named
lepus who um is a very competent
administrator and he has his own Army
and he actually wanted to avenge
Caesar uh but Mark stopped him okay so
lepidus is also part of the equation in
the center is a name named Cicero cisero
is considered one of the greatest
orators in Roman history um it was very
common it's very common as part of Liber
education to study the speeches of ciso
okay and ciso is the last remaining
optimate when the optimat are the ones
who are conservatives and who believe in
the pracy of the Senate so ciso is right
now in charge of the
Senate and everyone in this Game of
Thrones has a different motivation right
so ciso his main motivation is to
maintain the supremacy of the Senate so
he wants a balance of power so what he
will do is he will play everyone off
against each other in order to maintain
the supremacy of the Senate and
therefore his authority okay that's ciso
um Octavian wants to be the hear of
Caesar but so so is Mark Anthony and
lepides also wants to be a hear as well
and then on the other side our Decimus
Buddhist Marist Buddhist and Casas who
are fighting for their own legacy okay
so this is this is the situation in 44
BCE and it's a Game of Thrones
situation and you could you would
expect the one who would most likely
lose this game of thrones would be
Octavian right he's 18 years old he's
got no
Army uh and he has no allies in Rome
what happens over the next um 15 years
is one by one Octavian destroys all his
enemies what happens first is that Mark
Anthony goes to war with desus Buddhist
desus Buddhist is in charge of Gaul and
Mark Anthony wants the armies of desus
Buddhist so Mark Anthony marches against
desus Buddhist and then ciso to maintain
the amounts of power he authorizes
Octavian to raise his own Army to
challenge Mark Anthony okay so now
they're at war with each
other eventually Mark Anthony loses and
then he steals basically leop his army
to March against uh desus Buddhists
again and at this point what happens is
very strange the three of them lepidus
Octavian and Mark Anthony they sit they
sit down together and they they agree to
share power and form their own
dictatorship this is what we call the
second
triumphant okay the second serent is
brutal they the first one they decided
to do is kill all their enemies anyone
who could challenge them
including Cyro who was previously the
patrin of Octavia right so they killed
about a third of the Senate and replace
everyone with uh replace a senate with
their
allies then Mark Anthony Octavian
marched
against uh Marcus Buddhist and casassus
okay desus buddist has been destroyed
they now March against M Mar Marcus
Buddhist and cist and in 42 BCE they
fight the Battle of Philippi in macedone
in Macedonia okay Philippi is a city
named after King Phillip and in this
battle um Mark Anthony and Octavian
Triumph in the largest Battle in History
at that time okay and after this battle
where Marcus buddist and Cas are
killed um Octavian Mark Anthony and
lipides agree to Shear the world so
Octavian would get
Rome uh lipides would get Northern
Africa and Mark Anthony would get Egypt
and the near East Anatolia Syria so Mark
Anthony basically gets the line shear
of the Roman World okay and they agree
to share it then what happens is lepidus
comes into conflict with Mark Anthony
well sorry leopardus comes in conflict
with Octavian and
Octavian gives a speech to leopardus
soldiers who all defect over to Octavian
then Octavian comes in contct with Mark
Anthony and in 31
BCE at the Battle of um um
what what what what's that battle called
again 31 AUM sorry AUM in Greece it's a
huge battle where Anthony's forces are
aligned with Cleopatra forces
against um Octavian in this battle what
happens is uh basically Mark Anthony and
cleopetra they run away from the battle
where and then they return to
Alexandria and then um Octavian goes and
hunts them down and and they both commit
suicide before they're captured and then
this ends in 27 BC when Octavian returns
to the Senate the Roman senate in
Triumph and they declare him Augustus
Caesar okay Augustus Caesar his name has
out change to Augustus Caesar and he's
considered the first emperor of
Rome okay so this is the brief
history now I want to ask the question
how did Octavian again who in 44 BC he's
only 18 years old he has no Army and has
very few allies in Rome how is he able
to triumph over everyone okay all right
and there are different explanations um
the first you you can say it's just well
he got lucky
okay um yeah I know he I he was lucky
and that's that that is a possibility
but um
you don't become emperor by becoming
lucky okay so that's that that that
doesn't suffice second is you can say he
was
brilliant Julius Caesar was brilliant
right um King Philip alason was
brilliant these are all brilliant people
very few people say OCT um Octavian was
a brilliant person he didn't have the
Charisma of Julius Caesar his oration
was good but nowhere near as good as say
Mark Anthony's or or other Romans okay
and he and it was it's generally agreed
upon that he was a terrible terrible
military leader and strategist he want
he lost a lot of Wars sorry he lost a
lot of battles during this conflict okay
so he was not a great military leader so
he was not brilliant I mean he was
brilliant in his own way he was brilant
politically um but he was not brilliant
in the traditional sense Okay the third
explanation is well he's is ruthless he
will do anything for power and again
this is true there is some truth to this
but guess what in the Roman World
everyone was ruthless right Mark Anthony
was especially ruthless Mark Anthony
killed his own
wife okay so that doesn't explain it
fourth is um the legions the army they
remembered Caesar Julius Caesar and now
that Octavian is considered the son of
Julius Caesar
the legions swore loyalty to him and
that is true okay but they also swore
loyalty to Mark Anthony and you can you
can argue Mark anthy had a stronger
claim to Cesar's Legacy than Octavian so
that by itself doesn't explain it either
next explanation is
Marcus
agria and Marcus agria is considered um
octavian's partner and he was considered
a great General and it was actually
Marcus AG gria who was responsible for
all of octavian's major uh military
victories especially the Battle of
actium which which basically ended the
Civil
War and this again is true Marcus AGA is
a brilliant military leader but so were
cassus
desus okay there were other brilliant
military leaders the other issue is that
in this ruthless world of Roman
politics how could Octavian trust Marcus
Agrippa
and why did Marcus AGA stay loyal to
Octavian
okay okay so these are five explanations
and there's all some truth to that okay
but I want to offer you today another
explanation and the explanation is
this the death of Caesar allow Octavian
to become
emperor okay and here's my argument
remember last class we said that Caesar
his greatness was in his ma myth making
genius he created a myth of himself that
he was a man of Destiny who would save
the
Republic but his myth was counter to
other myths that were that were more
dominant in Rome especially the myth of
Lucius Buddhist right Lucius Buddhist
the man who created the Republic and
killed the
king and
so Caesar had this great myth but it was
against other dominant
myths when Caesar was killed it made his
myth the dominant myth of Rome in fact
it turned his myth into
reality and it was this new reality that
propelled
Octavian into
Power Okay so another simple way of
saying this is that it was the love of
the Roman people that propelled Octavian
into power and we see this in history
all the time right so for example um in
Canada douas from Canada so so am I
there's a man named Justin trudo the
most
incompetent person politician you will
ever meet okay but he's prime minister
and he's been prime minister for like 10
years right why because his father is
Pier too who is considered one of most
popular uh prime ministers in Kenan
history right so so it was basically
people's transferring their love of Pier
chudo onto the sun okay so that's one
example the other example of course in
America is George W bush right whose
father was George HW Bush who was
considered um you know a very good
president okay so is it yeah yeah do
just just to add in a little bit
thean
y
right that's right his legacy everybody
yeah that's right so so if you think
about it politics political change it's
really about of myths right if you want
to create political change you have to
change people's under you have to change
the myths and new governments will
create new myths okay all right great
all right so um that's a basic thesis
okay so let me explain it some more okay
so let's go back to the death of Julie C
the assassination of Julie C and um
there were three major assassins as I
said Decimus
Buddhist uh Marcus Buddhas who is the
leader in
casassus and they were just the leaders
of a huge conspiracy that involved 60
Senators that's about 7% of the Roman
senate that's a lot of people man right
7% of the Roman
senate and each of these individuals had
different reason for wanting Caesar
death okay so desus Buddhist was
considered Julie Caesar's most competent
General okay and he wanted to be
acknowled as such so you could say that
desus Buddhist he was driven by jealousy
or maybe fored
ambition okay you want to prove he prove
that he was better than Julius Caesar so
that's SES
Buddhas Cassius is a different story
cassus fought for Pompei the Great
and um because cassus was such a great
General Julius Caesar showed Mercy to
him and forgave him and made him a
general his his own General okay so this
is Caesar demonstrating his benevolence
and clemency and mercy the problem is
that in the Roman
World
Mercy um is not considered a good okay
so by showing Mercy on casassus cassus
could have interpreted interpreted this
as uh Caesar showing contemp for him
Caesar didn't really see him as a threat
okay and so C Cassis might have been
motivated by a sense like a desire for
vengeance right Marcus Buddhist is the
most interesting uh exam the most
interesting person here and actually you
know Shakespeare wrote a play
about Marcus Brutus called Julius Caesar
okay but it was really about Marcus
Brutus it was it was trying to explain
the psychology and motivations of why
Marcus Buddhist would want Caesar dead
Okay um Marcus Buddhist did fight for
pompe the
great but he's also the son of Julius
Caesar's favorite mistress favorite
lover and so Julius Caesar made a point
of telling his soldiers do not kill this
guy guy in battle if you see him capture
him and send him to me and so bu Buddhas
was Marcus buddist was captured and
Julius Caesar adopted him basically um
as a son and he basically um
fast-tracked Marcus buddist
career and so Marcus budus had every
reason to thank Julius Caesar right but
instead Marcus budus becomes the major
the main conspirator and in the play by
Shakespeare Julius Caesar uh the
argument that Shakespeare makes is
Marcus Buddhist is driven by his own
sense of virtue okay basically vanity he
he he believes or he's told that he's
named after lucus buddhis the found of
Republic and therefore he has a
responsibility to save the Republic from
wan to be tyrants like Caesar and that's
what drives him what what she doesn't
mention though is what Romans believe
is that Marcus Buddhist is the son the
biological son of Judas Caesar okay so
so maybe there was that inter personal
Dynamic where Marcus Buddhas
um despised
Caesar
okay right so it's a very complicated
situation but what unites
everyone
is that it's a feeling that Rome was
changing too fast okay okay so remember
Julius Caesar he did what he did in
order in order to save the Republic to
restore the Republic and so when he when
he had obtained power he was making
changes that were
necessary but which changed the Roman
sense of themselves okay so one example
is he brought in senators from the
provinces and these were Aristocrats who
spoke perfect Latin but because he was
from the provinces and there were
foreigners
the Roman people were very upset by this
okay that's the first thing second thing
is seizure anded corruption in the
provinces and that goes against the
interest of the nobility because one way
for you to become rich as a noble person
is to go to provinces and steal a lot of
money okay so Caesar was doing a lot of
things that were good for the Empire and
for the Republic in the long term but
which hurt the interests of um the
Senators and nobility in the short term
this is what caused the conflict
okay and
because Caesar was so fast and so
effective in its reforms it not only
sort of disturb the nobility but also
Disturbed the people as well because
Romans are very conservative they were
not used to all these changes happening
so fast and so this is what
compelled um the conspira to act against
Caesar okay but this race is a very
interesting question Caesar is a genius
he's brilliant how could he not see this
coming right how could he not
imagine the possibility that people were
conspiring against him and the answer
okay this this this is hard um for us to
understand today but it was unimaginable
that they would conspire to kill Caesar
in the Senate
okay so there are lots of
taboos in
Rome one major taboo is the idea of
the pr Miriam okay the promium is just
means the boundary of Rome and the idea
here is that Rome the city of Rome the
fiscal Geographic space of Rome it is
sacred and
divine it is protected by the god gods
and therefore you are not allowed to
bring weapons into Rome okay if you're a
soldier you must come in as a private
citizen you're not allowed to come in as
a soldier you are not allowed to commit
acts of violence within the
promium otherwise the gods will spite
you the go the gods will take Vengeance
against you okay so that's the first
taboo second taboo is
this the Senate is considered the most
most sacred and divine space in the
entire um in in all of
Rome and so no one's allowed to bring
weapons no no one's allowed to commit
violence in the Senate okay also the
Senate's laws are basically the laws of
the Gods the Senate
declared the body of Jud judices to be
sa okay meaning Divine and sacred you
are not allowed to touch the body of
Julius Caesar
Okay the third thing is that everyone in
the Senate was personally appointed by
Julius Caesar so everyone
owed their Good Fortune to the
generosity of Julius Caesar okay you you
understand it was just unimaginable for
Julius Caesar to think that his friends
could be conspiring against
him
okay does that make sense so far guys
okay was beyond on the
imagination
of um Julius
Caesar but if this is true then
something else is true which is that
Julius Caesar did not want to become
king because being King was the ultimate
Taboo in
Rome does does that make sense Julius
Caesar could not
imagine that budhist would kill him
because he like all Romans believed in
these
taboos and the ultimate taboo was wom
could never should never have a king so
he himself did not want to become king
he was behaving very arrogantly he was
behaving like a king but he did not him
but he would not become king himself
because it would go against the Roman
Republic it would defy all the taboos of
the Roman Republic okay and also before
Caesar there's also an another dictator
named Sola okay the example of Sola is
he's a man who comes into Power kills
all his enemies and then he retires okay
he could become king but he chose to not
become king because to become king would
mean the death of the Republic and
that's that taboo that's a Rubicon he
refused to cross okay so we can imagine
that Caesar saw himself as a better
solar okay as a more merciful Sola he
would not kill his enemies he would show
generosity to his enemies and he would
restore the Republic to its greatness he
would make the necessary reforms then he
would retire and lead the Republic as it
was
okay okay does that make sense all right
so it was unimaginable for
Caesar that to think that he'll be
killed and also what's interesting is
what do you think happened to these
three individuals after they killed
Caesar right they killed Caesar because
they feared Caesar would become king but
after they killed Caesar what they
recognize
is they could only kill
Caesar because Caesar did not want to
become king right otherwise Caesar would
surround himself with bodyguards
otherwise Caesar would not make himself
available to his enemies so a the death
of Caesar all his enemies tmus Marcus
and cus
realize they were in the wrong but not
only that but the very attitude of the
people of Rome changed
right uh while Caesar was alive the
Roman people were very skeptical towards
Caesar because they feared that he would
become king right they love Caesar but
they were afraid that Caesar was too
ambitious
but upon the death of Caesar the one
people felt tremendous guilt for
doubting
Caesar does that make sense right
because it was your doubt that allowed
the conspirators to kill Caesar if all
they did was believe in Caesar if they
believe that in Caesar's myth that he
was here as a man of Destiny to restore
the
Republic and that's all he cared about
he didn't want to become king then Cesar
would still be
alive okay and to compound the guilt
Caesar showered the people with
generosity upon his death
right okay so you can see how the death
of Caesar creates this new creates this
new reality where people now recognize
Caesar did not want to become king all
he wanted to do was save the
Republic and people are
now um they're sort of sort of
paralyzed by their guilt all
right so the evidence for this is
this while Decimus Brutus was being
attacked by Mark Anthony and then later
by
Octavian casassus told Marcus brutes hey
maybe we should come to this guy's Aid
he's our Ally if he falls they're going
to come after us next and Marcus Buddhas
did nothing he refused to act all right
and the reason why is he could not act
he killed Julius Caesar because Julius
Caesar was too ambitious but if Marcus
Buddhas were to move his Army against
Rome then Marcus Brutus is the ambitious
one he's the one who wants to become
king
right therefore Marcus Brutus and cases
could only wait for their
deaths because if they the case to
believe that Caesar wanted to become
king
wasn't true it could be true and
therefore they committed wrong against
Rome by killing
Caesar okay does that make sense so this
explains his enemies how about Mark
Anthony okay so Mark Anthony had a
different problem Mark Anthony loved
Caesar so much he wanted to continue
Caesar's
Legacy and Mark Anthony sort of felt
betrayed by Caesar when Cesar named
Octavian to be the hear and not Mark
Anthony okay and so what does Mark
Anthony want to do now well he wants to
prove
that Caesar is wrong Mark wants to prove
that he is the rightful
hear of Caesar and to prove so he will
continue his legacy okay so Mark Anthony
started to do some started to do things
that were against his own personal
self-interest and what which ultimately
led to his
self-destruction the first thing that he
did was he marched against the
parthians the parthians are Rome's last
great enemy okay Rome destroyed Carthage
Rome destroyed the Greeks but the
parthians still had an Empire to the
east of Rome and Romans Roman generals
uh fa to
make enrolls against against Parthia and
in fact Julius Caesar he wanted to
basically end his life by invading
partha okay so Julius Caesar's Plan
before his death was to attack partha
conquer it then sweep back to Europe and
Conquer Germany okay basically conquer
the whole world to prove he's better
than than a the
great so Mark eny decides that this is
how he will prove he is Caesar's
rightful here by finishing
seizures um Legacy against AP parthians
okay the problem is Romans are not good
again are not good at war against the
parthians and the Persians okay because
the Romans are infantry focus and the
parans and the Persians are Cavalry
Focus right they have horses so marinan
goes over to Parthia and he gets his ass
kicked all right he gets his askap he's
not Julius Caesar he's not the here to
Julius Caesar he and he falls into a
major depression he basically becomes a
drunk okay that's his first major
mistake second major mistake he makes is
he falls in love with
Cleopatra Cleopatra is the queen of of
Egypt but much more importantly she is
the Mistress of julus Caesar in fact
rumors were that upon his retirement
Julius Caesar would bring Cleopatra to
Rome and he would live happily ever
after okay that's the rumor so Mark
Anthony goes over to Egypt and he
becomes the lover to Cleopatra okay
because he's trying to be Julius Caesar
now and this is a problem because to to
marry Cleopatra he has to divorce his
wife who happens to be the sister of
Octavian okay so this causes a personal
riff between Octavian and Mark Anthony
the third thing that that he does which
is what causes his demise is he names in
his will okay he names it his will that
his children of
Cleopatra will become thees to the Roman
East all the property all that land that
um Mark the
controls will be given to his children
with Cleopatra they're foreign citizens
and also markon does not have the
authority to give that land out to his
children only the Senate has the
authority okay so Mark so Octavian used
the will as a pretext to attack Mark
Anthony and he's heavily supported by
the Roman people okay so what so Mark
Anthony because he's trying so hard to
escape the shadow of Julius Caesar
because he's trying so hard to prove he
is a legitimate he to jul Caesar he
basically self-destructs
he didn't have to do any of this but he
did and by doing all this it guarantees
his destruction
okay so Marky basically
self-destructs let's look at um lepidus
okay leopardus he is an extremely
effective
administrator but he is not as chartic
as charismatic and as brilant as J
Caesar and leopard is basically sh away
okay he didn't have the confidence to
challenge Octavian for the ultimate
power and seeing this lack of confidence
in this insecurity his soldiers
basically went off to join Octavian okay
and a lot of soldiers did that a lot of
soldiers that were fighting for the enem
side would just jump ship because
Octavian is the hear of Julius Caesar
okay he is the new Julius Caesar they
all worship Julius
Caesar
right now let's look at
Octavian why did Octavian exceed so much
again um he became partners with Marcus
agria who was a much better General than
him but
Octavian again he was not a brilant man
he was not charismatic he was not a
great General but he believed himself to
be the he to Julius Caesar for whatever
reason Julius Caesar believed in him and
therefore he had a
responsibility
to finish the legacy of his father okay
which is to restore the woman
Republic and that meant he had to do
whatever sacrifice was necessary in
order to do so
okay so the difference between uh
Octavian and the others was he
acted he wasn't very successful but he
was willing to act whereas Marcus Brutus
was not willing to act and when you
act sometimes you will succeed okay and
only a few successes will allow you to
become the the emperor of
Rome it was it was driven by the fact
that he believed himself to be the hear
of Julius Caesar he was a son of Julius
Caesar Julius Caesar believed in him
therefore has a
responsibility to restore the Republic
and that's why he trusted Marcus AG gria
okay and that's why Marcus AG gria
trusted him they were all fighting for
the legacy of Julius Caesar
and that's why ultimately the Roman
people allow Octavian to amass so much
power right
so remember ran people have been taught
to fear
Kings but over time Octavian was in
power for 40 years okay Augustus Cesar
was in power for 40 years over time he
became even more powerful than the King
this is what he did he amassed all
powers to himself after he conquered
Egypt he made Egypt into his own
personal property okay this was a
private
estate he used all the money from Egypt
again remember Egypt is right now and
for the longest time the wealthiest
country in in the world at this time
okay they have so much wealth he uses
money in order to have his own
Army before the Roman army was loyal to
the Senate now because it was octav
himself who personally paid every
soldier in the Army which is now a
professional Army they're now loyal to
the emperor okay he took Gaul which was
um you know which was land that Julia
Caesar basically de depopulated with
genocide and he gave the land to his
veterans okay so basically he made the
entire Army loyal to him personally so
he he now has the power of God the ROM
people allowed him to do that because
they believe that like Octavian sorry
like Julius Caesar Octavian was driven
by his sense of mission his desire to
save and restore the ran
Republic But
ultimately uh because they believed him
too much a Caesar would destroy the
Republic and concentrate all power in
his
hands okay does that make sense all
right any questions
yeah okay that's a great question okay
so why did Julius Caesar name Octavian
as it here and not Mark Anthony okay so
Octavian is the
great uh nephew of jsh Caesar so uh
Octavian was um Julius Caesar's
sister's uh grandson okay and so um
Octavian basic grew up with Julius
Caesar like they knew each other very
well but as Eko says Mark Anthony is
the man who is most loyal to Caesar okay
the the the most trusted Lieutenant of
Caesar why didn't Caesar trust him the
answer is Caesar as a genius he doesn't
care about loyalty he cares about Talent
he cares about ability and Mark Anthony
was a notorious hot head he had a
violent temper he was a drunk okay I
mean he he just had like Terri terrible
personal qualities so an example of this
is while um Caesar was off campaigning
against
Pompei he put Mark Anthony in charge of
Rome and all Mark Anthony did was piss
everyone off he got a fights with the
Senate he was so bad that that c had no
choice but to replace with lepidus okay
so Mark Anthony was in Tor hotthead he
was emotionally unstable he was
emotionally volatile and so Caesar
Caesar didn't really trust him even
though Mark Anthony Mark Anthony would
give his life for
Caesar does that make sense okay so
Octavian was considered much more
competent much more levelheaded and
Caesar was correct in his in his
assessment because Octavian was a
brilliant political manipulator okay
being an emperor is very hard he was
Emperor for 40 years so he had to
balance all these different political
factions within Rome okay so great
question Echo okay any more questions or
comments about this
argument is is all
clear sure give you a great the uh you
talking about how
yes that's
right I always that
yeah start thinking
ass that's right
that's
right yeah I mean it's it was very hard
to kill Caesar okay so they were in the
Senate there were 60 conspirators okay
they all brought knives they were they
theyit hit the knives the daggers in the
toga okay they were all supposed to like
lunch cesure
together so but when you but only five
Senators only five Senators actually
physically attacked Caesar everyone else
just stood paralyzed because as you as
you said it was taboo it was the
ultimate taboo to commit violence in the
Senate so they were all paralyzed by
this fear even though they had this
intense hatred of Caesar okay they they
they had for months imagine how they
would go about killing Caesar okay they
had plan they had they had this plan
meticulously but when it came to
actually acting it out they couldn't do
it only five actually managed to take
out their D and uh stab Caesar in fact
the first person who attacked Caesar um
stood behind Caesar uh while Caesar was
um making
talking to the Senate and he was shaking
okay and he only managed to like pin
prick Caesar in the back okay this is
where we get the idea of backstabbing
from so and it and Cesar didn't really
notice he was like hey what are you
doing man okay Cesar wasn't really hurt
by this even Caesar even though he was
being attacked could not imagine that
anyone would be so bold enough to break
all these
taboos and attack him okay so uh um I
mean it was a it was um incredible act
that forever changed woman history all
right it was it was just unimaginable
that anyone could attack anyone in the
Senate like physically okay
especially um the dictator the Julius
Caesar who was considered Divine and
Sacred by the Roman people okay so it
was an
incredible act of violence okay and only
five people actually participated in
attacking him and it took a very long
time because it was so hard to must the
strength to stab Caesar and again all
the Senators are like soldiers okay
they're physically very strong they're
General they're used to killing people
it wasn't fear of death it was just fear
of bringing this ultimate taboo of the
Roman senate okay so thank thanks for
that Doug any any more questions before
I
finish okay okay so
um Octavian Augustus Caesar was
considered the first and the greatest
emperor of the Roman
Empire and like Julius Caesar him he did
not consider himself the emperor he
considered himself like First Citizen
okay or the first man in the Senate and
his responsibility was to
ensure the Eternal prosperity and
stability of the uh Roman Republic and
so um towards towards um his old age he
had to consider the public sorry he had
to consider the problem problem of
secession right he was a great emperor
but the second Emperor had to be had to
be great as
well and so his solution was this his
solution would be he would
adopt the most competent relative that
he had to be Emperor and he create this
new system where Emperors would be
adopted okay so the best man in Rome
would always be adopted into the
Imperial throne and um Augustus Caesar
had the perfect man his name is
germanicus germanicus was very much like
Julius Caesar brilliant speaker loved by
his soldiers the problem was that he was
too young okay Jus was too young so he
needed a
transition and so he appointed his
stepson
Tiberius um who was pretty old at this
point okay to be the transition
tiberious was not
charismatic um he was not very popular
but he was competent he was a comp
competent administrator he'd be Emperor
for like five to 10 years and then when
germanicus um was came of age then
germanicus would inherit the throne and
he' be a good Emperor and as a good
Emperor you would then you would you
would then be able to find someone else
who had who who had good talent and you
would appoint him the next Emperor if
you had this system this system could go
on forever
right and so this is BR
system the problem was hiberus okay
tyberius didn't like the
idea that he could not appoint his
sucessor okay so what did he do well he
killed dramaticus
but not only did he kill germanicus he
killed um
basically all of germanicus family okay
and not only did he kill janus's family
but he killed well he killed a lot of
people
okay and then he adopted someone named
Kula um who was janica's um youngest
son um to be the emperor and kaga was a
notoriously bad Emperor okay so this
system broke down very
quickly even though Augustus Caesar his
intention was to um uh continue the
legacy of Julius Caesar and create an
eternal prosperity for the Roman
Republic okay and with by the time you
got to tiberious the system
collapsed and you could make the
argument that uh tiberious marked the
death of the Roman Empire okay the Roman
Empire will continue for another like
300 years
but it's basically
dead Okay meaning that it was racked by
all these internal Revolt internal
tensions and it was only because of its
size and inertia was able to continue
for so
long okay so um we will next class we
will
finish Rome by
discussing uh the Roman Legacy okay what
is Rome's contribution to western
civilization and this will mainly have
to do with
um the legacy of Augustus
Caesar right any
questions okay all right great so uh we
will continue we will finish with Rome
next class and then we'll start Egypt
okay and Egypt will be a lot of fun